so what we have in this chart is all the
numbers from 1 to 100 organized in a
fairly neat way it's a somewhat
intuitive way to organize it where each
row you have 10 so you go from 1 to 10
then 11 to 20 then 21 to 30 all the way
to 100 and we're going to look at is
interesting patterns that might emerge
from this
so if you look at what's highlighted
here in this purplish color what numbers
are highlighted there pause this video
and think about it
well what's highlighted are all of the
even numbers and you can see the even
numbers form these nice neat pillars or
columns on this chart and we can look at
that and immediately start to see some
patterns for example what numbers all
are always going to be in the ones place
for an even number looking at this chart
well you can see in the ones place
you're either always going to have a 2
in the ones place
or
you're going to have a 4
or you're going to have a 6 or you're
going to have an 8 or you're going to
have a 0. so that one's place digit is
always going to be an even number
let's do another example
here we've highlighted highlighted
different numbers so pause this video
and think about what's true about all of
the numbers that we've highlighted
well you might notice that these are all
multiples of five 5 10 15 20 25 30 35 40
so on and so forth and so these form
these two columns on this chart
and here we can see very clearly that
multiples of five are either going to
have a 5 in the ones place
like we have right over here
so they're either going to have a 5 in
the ones place
or they're going to have a 0 in the ones
place you might have realized that
before but you see it very clearly in
these two you see it very clearly in
these two columns
let's do one other example
this one is really interesting because
it's not just one of those clean column
type patterns it looks like we start at
one and then we have this diagonal and
then we go to 100 what's a what's a
pattern that could describe how we go
from one number to the next or another
way of of saying it what's a rule for
why we highlighted these numbers in
purple pause the video and think about
that
all right well one thing is if we go
from one number to the next to go from 1
to 10 we add 9 to go from 10 to 19 we
add 9 to go from 19 to 28 we added 9. so
each number is 9 plus the previous one
and if you go all the way to 91 91 plus
9 is of course 100.
now it's important to realize these are
not multiples of 9 because we started at
1 not at zero if you started at zero you
go zero nine eighteen so forth and so on
and so you go nine eighteen twenty seven
thirty six forty five fifty four sixty
three seventy two eighty one those would
have been the multiples of nine but
everything got shifted because we
started at one not at zero so we go from
1 and then 10 19 28 all the way down
this diagonal and then we go back to 100
and so this is a really interesting
thing to think about these are all the
multiples of 9 plus 1 is another way to
think about it or this is if we started
at 1 and we keep adding 9s these are all
the numbers that we would highlight but
you can see a pattern whenever you add 9
to a number the value of the ones place
decreases by one you see that here as
you go down these diagonals you go from
9 8 7 6
5 4 3
2
1. and even up here we started at 0 but
you don't have a lower digit than 0 so
it just goes back to 9. so it goes 0
then goes up to 9 then it keeps going
down down down down all the way until it
gets to 0 again and then it starts going
down from there again so once again
interesting patterns to look at i
encourage you to look at a chart like
this and think about what patterns can
you find